ciao tutto quello che va dal 50 per
cento giusto ma poi c'è scritto sconti
fino al 50 per cento potuto prendere
giro la gente o poi signorina seconda
lei no vieni poetiche alto 185
corporatura mi sono occhi azzurri
capelli o anni può stare bene cirina
ecco queste sono al 30 giusto si e con
quanto lamentare che il 50 allora devo
fare un regalo a mia mamma non sono
taglio come ti posso dire altro ma tanta
come voi a signora league bond secondo
te ha detto gli occhi quindi rosa sulla
50 e quelli nere roma ti sei sullo
stesso modello 6 tematizzano nokia mi
faccio il 50 per cento quelle nere che
ne vedo molte di più sempre con te a me
la prendo per i matrimoni di tuo cugino
bravo però mi dentro tutti i modi
rimangono signorina scusi queste ciglia
il 37 sono ancora nun te va bene prendo
lo stesso ma scommetto una soletta ne
facciamo così io non li prendo le mie
vita da parte appena arriveranno a 50
per cento le mi fa vecchio noti vi posso
prenderle punto 89 euro ma allora la 50
per cento augura sconto modo ma figure
diamo lascia stare tanto manco mi
piaceva